[موسيقى]
اسرائيليه ومطالبه فلسطينيه متكرره بوضع
اسرائيل
قامت الممثله الامميه الخاصه بالاطفال
الغربيه للاطلاع عن قرب على اوضاع الاطفال
الفلسطينيين ورفع تقريرا الى الامين العام
للامم المتحده بشان الانتهاكات
الاسرائيليه بحقهم زياره المسؤوله الامميه
في جنين كما تاتي بعد نحو اسبوعين فقط من
تصريحات لرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيليه
المنتهيه ولايته بان اسرائيل لن تسمح ابدا
بتحقيقاتها من قبل جهات اجنبيه ولن تقبل
التاشيره بهم فكيف ستتعامل اسرائيل مع هذه
الزياره ونتائجها التي قد تؤكد الممارسات
المنهجه لقوات الاحتلال منذ عقود ضد
الاطفال الفلسطينيين وهل تستطيع منظمه
الامميه اصدار تقرير رسمي يدرج اسرائيل
على القائمه السوداء للدول التي تعرض حياه
الاطفال للخطر اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من
سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم بشكل ممهج تواصل اسرائيل
الانتهاكاتها الجسيمه لحقوق الفلسطينيين
ومن بينهم الاطفال القصر في خرق فاضح
للمواثيق والقوانين الدوليه عن هذه
الانتهاكات والدلائل التي قدمتها السلطه
الفلسطينيه للمسؤوله الامميه والنتائج
المحتمله لزيارتها يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في
هذه الحلقه هنا في الاستديو الدكتور احمد
الطيبي النائب العربي في الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي من رام الله الدكتور عمر عوض
الله مساعد وزير الخارجيه الفلسطيني للامم
المتحده ومنظماتها المتخصصه من نيويورك
الدكتور عبد الحميد الصيام الخبير في شؤون
الامم المتحده وسينضم الينا لاحقا من
القدس
مديره منظمه انقذ الاطفال في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله
الاسرائيليه بحق الاطفال الفلسطينيين تشمل
سوء المعامله والعنف الجسدي وهجمات على
مراكز الصحيه ومستشفيات ومدارس بالاضافه
الى جرائم القتل وقالت الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه ان اسرائيل قتلت ما يزيد عن 52
طفلا فلسطينيا منذ مطلع العام الحالي
واشارت الى ان الطرق القتل تعدد منها عن
طريق رصاص الجيش والقوات الامنيه
الاسرائيليه او عن طريق اعتداءات نفذها
المستوطنون وكذلك لاهمال الطبيه داخل
السجون
من جانبها اشارت وحده الدراسات والتوثيق
في هيئه شؤون الاسرى والمحررين الى ان
الاحتلال اعتقل 815 طفلا منذ مطلع العام
الجاري ومازال يحتجز في سجونه نحو 150
طفلا في حين وثقت مؤسسات حقوقيه فلسطينيه
انا اسرائيل اعتقلت خلال شهر نوفمبر تشرين
الثاني الماضي 490 فلسطينيه من بينهم 76
طفله وقالت ملاسقه الامم المتحده لشؤون
الانسانيه روسيا علمي ان العام 2022 هو
الاكثر دمويه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه منذ
16 عاما
واستعدت المسؤوله الامميه ان يشكل الضحايا
التهديدا حقيقيا لتبرير استخدام القوه
المميته من قبل قوات الاحتلال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يشيع الفلسطينيون جثمان الطفله جنى زكارنه
بينما تمضي قدما مساعد سلطه الفلسطينيه
لادراجي اسرائيل في قائمه الامم المتحده
للجهه والدول التي تنتهي بحقوق الاطفال في
النزاعات المسلحه او ما تعرف بالقائمه
السوداء او قائمه العار برصاص اسرائيلي
قتلت جنى
على سطح بيتها العائلي في جنين بينما كان
جنود الاحتلال بصدد ملاحقه مطلوبين كما
زعمت اسرائيل ليس من قبيل الصدفه انت زمن
ذلك مع زياره الممثله الخاصه للامين العام
للامم المتحده المعنيه بالاطفال
الفلسطينيين طويله وقد سلمت السلطه
الفلسطينيه المسؤوله الامميه تقريرا مفصلا
بجرائم الاحتلال بحقهم وذكر بيانه
للخارجيه الفلسطينيه ان الجرائم التي
تضمنها التقديره تندرج ضمن قرار مجلس
الامن 26 و12 الصادر عام 2005 الذي يشمل
قتلى وتشويه الاطفال واستهداف المدارس
والمستشفيات وتجنيد الاطفال والاعتداءات
الجنسيه و خطف الاطفال ومنع وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه والطبيه لكن سلطات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حريصه على ترميم
سمعتها بشان هذه الانتهاكات وتعمل جاهده
لا يتم ادراجها في قائمه سنويه تصدرها
الامم المتحده للجهات والدول التي تنتهي
حقوق الاطفال في النزاعات المسلحه حسب
القناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه يكون
المسؤولون الاسرائيليون قد زودوا فرجينيا
كامبا بما يقولون انه دليل على ان معظم
القاصرين الفلسطينيين الذين قتلوا على يد
القوات الاسرائيليه كانوا متورطين مع
مجموعات مسلحه وانخرته في نشاط عسكري او
شبه عسكريا
زعمت مصادر الدبلوماسيه للقناه
الاسرائيليه ان الامر يتعلق بمعلومات عن
تجنيد الاطفال والمراهقين وتدري على
الاسلحه واستخدام مدارس الاونروا ملاجئ
للارهابيين حسب وصفهم
المسؤوله الامميه اختتمت زيارتها الى
الاراضي الفلسطينيه الخميس بلقاء رئيس
الوزراء الفلسطيني محمد شتيه وهي زياره
استمرت اربعه ايام التقت خلالها مسؤولين
من الجانبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيليه ينتظر
الان معرفه ما اذا كانت الادله الفلسطينيه
المقدمه لها كفيله بادراج اسرائيل في
قائمه العار بسبب انتهاكاتها البينه لحقوق
الاطفال ام ان في المزاعم الاسرائيليه ما
قد يكون دون ذلك
الدكتور احمد الطيب اهلا وسهلا بك اهلا
وسهلا لماذا تبدو المؤسسه السياسيه
والامنيه الاسرائيليه متوجهه الى الى هذا
الحد من زياره جامبا وما يمكن ان يتبخر
عنها
يتم قتل الفلسطينيين دون رقابه دون حساب
دون زياره
في الماضي كان محاولات لزياره مندوبين
ومسؤولين من الامم المتحده او لجان تحقيق
ورفضت ورفض الاحتلال ذلك وهذه المره بما
انه
تسليط الضوء يتم على قتل واستهداف اطفال
الحساسيه اكبر
وخاصه انها جاءت وتزامنت في نفس اليوم
الذي ارتقت فيه الطفله جنه ذكرني ابنه
السادسه عشر شهيده برصاص ايه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ورد الفعل الاسرائيلي كان
تقليديا متوقعا الرد الاول قال انه مش
احنا بعدين قالوا شو بتساوي على السطوح ما
الذي تفعله الطفله على سطح منزلها
بعدها قالوا انه يبدو انها كانت تراقب
تحركات جنود الاحتلال لتنقل ذلك الى
المقاومين ثم بعدها قالوا يبدو انه بالخطا
القناص الاسرائيلي اصابها في راسها بالخطا
بدي اعطي ملاحظه عن كلمه القناص
الاسرائيلي هذا القناصفه مراسل المراسل
العسكري للقناه الثانيه بانه قناص بارع
ومليء بالاوسمه انا بعرف انه القناص عندما
يكنس
ينظر في العدسه واذا هو بارع يصيب هدفه
بدقه
واطلق 9 تقريبا
روايات اما اصابها في مقتل
تذكر عندما ارتكت الشهيده شيرين ابو عقلي
ايضا من اطلق النار هو النار على فكره هم
يعرفون هويه القناص الذي اصاب شيرين وان
قناص الذي اصاب جنى
ماذا جرى لهؤلاء القناصين لهؤلاء الجنود
الذين قتلوا شيرين ابو عاقله وجنى ذكرني
لا شيء اسرائيل تتباها او
تستعمل امكانيه التحقيق الداخلي لصد
امكانيه التحقيق الخارجي
زياره من مبعوثه الامم المتحده والتحقيق
الداخلي يكون طبطبه
غطاء
نصب واحتيال كذب وتضليل
بعض الذين اطلقوا النيران على اطفال
فلسطينيين تم ترقيتهم بالجيش الاسرائيلي
والراي العام يتقبل ذلك لانه دائما
اسرائيل تقدم نفسه على انها تتبع المنظومه
الغربيه في احترام حقوق الانسان وغير ذلك
على الاقل بالنسبه لرايها العام الداخلي
لن نتحدث عن الضفه الغربيه وغزه يعني
تسويقه داخليه
اذا كان المقياس المنظومه الغربيه مثلا
انه الغرب امريكا فرنسا قتلو مليون عراقي
هذه هذه لم يحاسب احد عليها اذا هذه هي
القيم الغربيه ولكن
ما من شك في ان الجانب الاسرائيلي
والجمهور الاسرائيلي والاعلام الاسرائيلي
تحديد الجمهور
بمعنى انه فقد اي مشاعر
تجاه اي خبر بيسمعه انه قتل طفل فلسطيني
الرد ال اول يكون لا رد انا اريد ان اقول
لك عندما نشرت انا في تغريده في تويتر عن
الشهيده جنى
رد علي صحفي مصور في وكاله اعلام وموقع
اسرائيلي مشهور
وقال
ان رد علي اول نشر انه اذا الان هي طفله
فمن المؤكد انها ستصبح مخربه وكان من
الاشجر ان تقتل وتموت الان
توجهت للمسؤول عليه في وسائل وسيله
الاعلام وقال هذا موقف الشخصي ليس موقفنا
تصور لو صحفي عربي او مصور عربي في وسيله
اعلام اسرائيليه كتب شيء مشابه لن يبقى في
منصب او وظيفته خمس دقائق هذا هو المعيار
المزدوج وانا اعود واكرر ان المجتمع
الاسرائيلي لا يبدي بغلبيته طبعا هناك ناس
متنورين شريحه قليله لا يبدي اي مشاعر ولا
يريد ان يعرف ماذا يحدث في الساحه الخلفيه
المسمى الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله على
ذكر هذه
الاسرائيلي ساعود بعد ذلك لمقال جميل
نسال الدكتور عمر عبد الله من رام الله
اهلا وسهلا بك همم
في الملف الذي قدمته السلطه للمبعوثه
الامميه على ماذا تم التركيز بشكل خاص
لضيوفك الكرام بالطبع
الملف ركز على جرائم التي ارتكبت بحق
الاطفال الاطفال يجب عدم استهدافهم تحت اي
ظرف من الظروف ولا يمكن ادعاء كل هذه
الادعاءات حول الاطفال ما اذا كانوا
مخربين او غير مخربين
الملف الذي قدم قدم باتجاهين الاتجاه
الاول هو تلك الجرائم التي يحتويها قرار
مجلس الامن 16 12 والذي شكل ولايه ممثله
الامين العام فرجينا كامبا وهو الحديث عن
استهداف الاطفال اعتقالهم التعسفي استهداف
في المدارس والمستشفيات واماكن تواجدهم
وتجديد وقضيه اخذ الاطفال كدروع بشريه
وكذلك الاتجاه الاخر هي جرائم الحرب
وجرائم ضد الانسانيه لان نفس هذه الورقه
تم تكييفا بشكل قانوني وتقديمها للمدعي
العام للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه وسرت واضح
باسماء الاطفال
واماكن اصاباتهم وكيفيه اصاباتهم
وشهادات حول ما تعرضوا لهم هؤلاء الاطفال
بمعنى يثبت بان هؤلاء الاطفال قد تم
اعدامهم ميدانيا
تم استهدافهم بشكل عامد كما جاء في تقرير
لجنه التحقيق الدوليه اثناء مسيرات العوده
عندما قالت اللجنه ان اسرائيل تستهدف
الاطفال عمدا وهذا ضمن سياسه من منهجه
وواسعه النطاق لاسرائيل الاستهداف اطفال
فلسطين لغرضين الغرض الاول هو
تخريب مستقبل الشعب الفلسطيني وانهاء
مستقبل الشعب الفلسطيني وثانيا الترحيل
القصري للشعب الفلسطيني لانه الفلسطينيين
بكل بكل فئاتهم وكل
واينما كانوا يتواجدوا يريدون ان يحموا
اطفالهم وان يحموهم من هذه
المنظومه الاستعماريه المجرمه التي ترتكب
جرائم بشكل يومي بحق الاطفال هذا ما تم
تكيفه وتقديمه الى ممثله الامين العام
بالدلائل والوثائق التي تثبت ارتكاب
اسرائيل لهذه الجرائم ضد الاطفال في
النزاعات المسلحه هي هي المبعوثه الاميه
الدكتور عبد الحميد سام ربما تبدو محظوظه
بالنسبه لغيرها لان على الاقل وصلت والتقت
بالمسؤولين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين هل
في الامم المتحده التعامل مع ملف قتل
الاطفال ربما اسهل وايسر من التعامل والتح
في جرائم اسرائيل بشكل عام
شكرا اخي محمد تحيه لك وضيوفك وللمشاهدين
الكرام
الحقيقه ان هذا الطلب لزياره الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله وزياره اسرائيل
مدرجا منذ عام 2017 تاخرت كثيرا في هذه
الزياره
وعندما يبدا كتابه التقرير تحاول اسرائيل
اما ان تاخذ بعض القرارات التي تبين انها
تحسن من ادائها في معامله الاطفال
الفلسطينيين او انها هذه المره سمحت
للسيده فرجينيا جامبا بزياره المنطقه
لكن طبعا هناك تعاطف شديد ومعظم قرارات
مجلس الامن اعتمدت بالاجماع فيما يتعلق
بدور هذه همم هذه الاجنه وانشاء المكتب
الخاص بمراقبه همم اوضاع الاطفال في مناطق
الصراعات المسلحه والذي انشئ عام
1997 ثم اصبح
يعني يقوم بدور اوسع بعد قرار 1612 في عام
2005 ثم ااا وسع دور هذه
اللجنه لتضع قائمه ملحقه بالت همم الثانوي
والذي نسميها قائمه العار واول قائمه عار
وضعت عام عن احداث 2015 عندما كانت همم
الممثل ممثله الامين العام السيده ليلى
زروكي ووضعت اسرائيل في القائمه ووضعت دول
التحالف همم التحالف العربي الذي التي
كانت تشن غارات على اليمن وكما تعرفون انه
همم اقيمت الدنيا على القائمه وتم سحب اسم
اسرائيل
بضغوطات خلفيه يعني عندما وضع التقرير بين
اعضاء
مجلس الامن كان اسم اسرائيل محذوفا واما
اسم التحالف فقد حذف فيما بعد
بسبب تحديدا لذلك يعني هناك يتعرض الامين
العام لضغوطات غير معقوله حتى لا يكون همم
اسم هذه الدوله او تلك
في القائمه السوداء يعني يتحملون ان يكون
في التقرير هناك حوالي 10 فقرات في اخر
تقرير عن عام 2021 عن فلسطين لكن ان يوضع
في القائمه السوداء فهذه
المشكله بالنسبه لهذه الدول وتعمل كل ما
في جهدها حتى لا تكون ضمن قائمه القائمه
السوداء الدكتور طيب اسرائيل بالطبع همم
عندما تقول انها همم
ستقدم بعض المقاطع
الفيلميه والوثائق التي تثبت انها كانت في
وضع همم اضطرت فيه بين قوسين
لقتلها اولياء الاطفال هذا النوع من الحجج
مدعوم بشكل جيد على الاقل من ناحيه
التقنيه حتى اليوم في القضايا الكبيره
والاسماء التي افتكرت
والشهداء لا في موضوع شيرين ولا في موضوع
جنى ولا في عشرات الاطفال لم تبرز اي شريط
فيديو يثبت ما تقول ثم ما الذي يبرر قتل
طفل ما الذي يبرر
هي تريد ان تمثل في جثامين الشهداء
الاطفال حتى بعد موتهم بالادعاء بانهم
مخربين وهم اطفال فلسطينيين يعني
اسرائيل تريد ان تمنع من الفلسطين مش بس
ان يتنفس ان يعيش بشكل حر وان يتنقل بحريه
ان يعترض على امكانيه ان يقتل بمعنى هذا
الرصاص الاسرائيلي الذي يتجول بحريه
الرصاص رصاص الاحتلال يتجول بحريه بازقه
المخيمات والمدن والكره الفلسطينيه
ممنوع على اي طفل فلسطيني ان يصطدم
برصاسهم الرصاص مسموح اما ان يصطدم
الرصاص يوجه الى صدور ناس ابرياء اسرائيل
تدعي انه خطا انا الان من على منبر
الجزيره بدي اقول يا سيدي نفرض اسرائيل
اخطات مره نقبلها بلاش مره مرتين بلاش
مرتين اخي محمد عشر مره ولكن منذ عقد منذ
عشر سنوات عدد الاطفال الفلسطينيين الذين
س وارتقوا شهداء برصاص الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كم اكثر من 740 طفل وفتى اقل
من 18 عام اعود واكرر الرقم خلال عقد
740 شهيد طفل فلسطيني تقريبا
هؤلاء كلهم اخطاء
طبعا لا ولكن اسرائيل تعودت على عدم
المحاسبه
الاحتلال غير مكلف وقتل الفلسطينيين حتى
عندما يكونوا اطفال غير مقرف وهي لا تريد
لا للزياره ولا الاعتراض ولا لجنازه كبيره
حتى انها تعتدي على جنازات جنازات اطفال
جنازات صحفيين وهذا هو الواقع الفلسطيني
وهو مدير منظمه انقذوا الاطفال في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله همم اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
جيسون لي همم كيف تابعتم زياره السيده
فرجينيا جنبه
لاسرائيل والاراضي الفلسطينيه
هاي كريم
موجوده
خلال هذه الزياره التقت بها اطراف
النزاع وان نحن نطلع الى نسمع
اراءها وحولك الجميع للتاكد انه احترام
الالتزامهم بحمايه الاطفال ولكن هل هل على
الاقل طلبت منكم اللقاء لانه يفترض انتم
يعني محايدين بين قوسين لستم للطرف
الفلسطيني ولا الطرف الاسرائيلي
امم افريقيا
كان في مجال لنا طلبنا اجتماعا معها لكن
كان لديها التزامات اخرى خاصه المتعلق
باللقاء باطراف النزاع لكننا نعمل تستح
لنا الفرصه لتقدم لها بيانات حول طريقه
حول الانتهاكات تحت ضد الاطفال في الاراضي
المحتله هل لديكم على الاقل طريقه لايصال
هذه البيانات حتى لو لم تلتقوا بها
امين كل البيانات التي نشرناها في تقارير
عديد منقذ الاطفال من ذلك بيانات المتوفره
عن طريق اوتشا اييي كلها تعطي صوره داكنه
وتبين هناك انتهاكات كثيره ضد الاطفال
اعداد كبيره للاطفال
فقط 35
يعدد الاطفال الجرح اكثر من 800 طفل صيبه
بجروح فقط هذه السنه وعشره بينهم عن طريق
استخدام
على ان تجعل منها جزء لا باس به من
التقرير السيده
امين كل البيانات التي تجمع الشركاء
والامم المتحده كل هذه المعلومات تغذى
وتدخل في مكتب المكتبه ومع ذلك تعقل عديده
التي قد نفوز الاطفال
والتوثيقات التي تقدمها لحوادث القتل قتل
الاطفال وعدد الهجمات على الموسات تعليميه
خمسه 55 مدرسه الضفه الغربيه معرضه
للتهديم حاليا والسنه مره كان هناك مدرسه
واحده في صهيب جرى تدميرها
22 طفل كل هذه المعلومات جمعت وقدمت مره
اخرى كلها قدمناها الى الى عن طريق قنوات
الامم المتحده وبالتالي
الممثل
السيد غامبول اللي هيحصل على هذه
المعلومات والبيانات وكل جزء من المجتمع
المدني من المجتمع على الانسان في الاراضي
المحتله نحن نتاكد من التقديم هذه
البيانات واستنتاجات للتاكد منها تظهر في
الاجراءات وفي التقارير الدوميه هل تلقيتم
ولو لمره واحده ردا اسرائيليا رسميا يحاول
ان يفسر او يبرر او يشرح هذه الحالات
الكثيره
مره اخرى
تنسيق مع الجميع اطراف النزاع وكل عاد فان
استنتاجاتنا نعرضها ونقدمها الى السلطات
الاسرائيليه
ونطلب منهم ان يدرسوا طريقه يمكن ان يوفي
بالتزاماتهم بحمايه الاطفال شكرا جزيلا لك
سيد جسم لمدير منظمه انقذ الاطفال في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله كنت معنا همم
من القدس
نعود الى الدكتور عمر عوض الله نريد الان
ان نبحث موضوع قائمه العالم كما تسمى همم
الجانب الفلسطيني يطمح لادراج اسرائيل
تقاوم الولايات المتحده تدعمها في ذلك همم
ربما الان المبعوثه الاميه تتعرض والامم
المتحده تتعرض لضغوطات كيف ستتعاملون مع
هذه المساله
يعني حاولنا منذ منذ ان تم انشاء هذه
القائمه قائمه العار وبناء على الولايه
الخاصه بقرار مجلس الامن خطبنا المدير
العام بعديد المخاطبات والتقينا به خاصه
بعد ان تراجع في احدى الدورات وكان كوفي
عنان انذاك تراجع من ادراج اسرائيل الشوط
القائم بالاحتلال ومستوطنيها على لائحه
العار خاصه وان الممثله الامين العام انا
ذاك
ومنظمه اليونيسيف اكدت ان اسرائيل تنتهي
الجرائم الجسيمه الست المدرجه تحت قرار
مجلس الامن ولكن طبعا تحت الضغوط يعني
الامين العام تراجع عن ادراج السلطه
القائم بالاحتلال وهذا شكل غضب كبير حقيقه
لدى الدبلوزير الفلسطينيه وارسلنا رسائل
والتقينا به وتحدثنا معه بطريقه يعني حاده
جدا بعد ذلك عملنا على اعداد تقاريرنا
الوطنيه بحيث ان تشمل كل الجرائم ترتكبها
اسرائيل وان يكون تقريرا وطنيا يسلم الى
مساله الامين العامه ويسلم الى اليونيسيف
ويسلم الى الامين العام من خلال بعثتنا في
همم في نيويورك التي قابلت عديد المرات
الممثله والام العام العمل داؤوب على قضيه
ادراج همم اسرائيل على لائحه العام هي
ومستوطنيها في نفس الوقت
التقرير الاخير للامير العام بعد كل هذا
العمل منا ومن المجتمع المدني ومن كل
منظمات الامم المتحده المتخصصه بشان
الطفوله وصلنا الى ان الامين العام لم
يستطع ان يفلت هذه المره من قضيه عدم
ادراج اسرائيل ونها في تقريره الذي ورد في
2021 بانه اسرائيل انه يراقب اسرائيل جيدا
بما تقوم به من انتهاكات بحق الاطفال
الفلسطينيين وباحنه في حال اسرائيل لم
تتراجع عن عن ارتكاب هذه الجرائم بانه سوف
ياخذ
باتجاه هذه القضيه وبالفعل اسرائيلي بعد
ذلك قامت بعنوان على قطاع غزه عندما عندما
استشهد اكثر من اربعه 10 طفله الان
المعلومات تسلم الى هذه
الهيئه الامميه الامين العام وفرجينا
قامبل الان استلمت قائمه من ابنائنا
الاطفال الشهداء اكثر من 52لا وكلها مكيف
بناءا على قواعد القرار مجلس الامن 16
والان الكره في ملعب هذه المنظومه الدوليه
وقلنا لهم ان التجربه وان الاختبار
الحقيقي لكم هي فلسطين وتخاذلكم في فلسطين
هو تخاذل في كل مكان في العالم وما زلنا
مستمرين حقيقه في العمل وفي الضغط على
الامين العام لتحمل المسؤولياته تحت هذه
الولايه وما زلنا نضغط بهذا بهذا الاتجاه
الكره وهي في ملعب الامم المتحده همم
دكتور عبد الحميد صيام ما الذي سيفعل بها
نعم
اوضح بعض النقاط
اولا ليس من مسؤوليه
فرجينيا كامبا وضع قائمه العار بل من
مسؤوليه الامين العام وعندما اصدرت
تقريرها السابق وعقدت مؤتمر صحفي في الامم
المتحده سالتها انا بنفسي قلت لها كيف لا
تدرجين اسرائيل رغم ان التفاصيل الموجوده
في التقرير كلها تشير الى ارتكابها تلك
الجرائم السته التي يتضمنها تتضمنها ولايه
البعثه قالت في الاخير انا اضع هذه
المعلومات بين ايدي الامين العام وهو الذي
يقرر كما قلت من قبل بانكيمون هو الذي سحب
اسم اسرائيل في عام 2016 وكانت بعد بعد
حرب 2014 انا اقول لك ان التقرير الاخير
وقد صدر في يونيو هذا العام
حزيران يونيو عن 2021 يتحدث عن مقتل 86
طفل فلسطيني
17 منهم في الضفه الغربيه والباقي في غزه
على اثر العدوان عام 2021 يتحدث عن
استهداف 22 مدرسه و 61
مؤسسه او عياده طبيه تتعلق
بالميدان الصحي وكذلك هناك حوالي
9900 و800 انتهاء كافه الاشكال ومعظمها
على الفلسطينيين يعني اثنين اسرائيليين
قتلوا كما جاء في التقرير
وهناك بعض الحوادث تنسب الى بعض الفصائل
تجنيد شخص واحد كما جاء في التقرير شخص
واحد ثم
انتقد كذلك قيام المعسكرات الطلابيه والتي
تاتي الفصائل وتدرب بعض الط على استخدام
السلاح او او تظهر لهم السلاح بهذا الشكل
اذا كل شيء يشير الى ان اسرائيل يجب ان
تكون ضمن قائمه العار لكن ما يجري في همم
في الكواليس او خلف الكواليس هي المصيبه
هي المصيبه ان هناك دول تملك تملك القوه
وتضغط على الامين العام وتجبره على ان
يسحب اسم اسرائيل ودول اخرى ليس فقط
اسرائيل يعني لم يدرج يا جماعه ما قامت به
الولايات المتحده من جرائم همم في
افغانستان ولا في العراق ولا جرائم مثلا
ارتكبها ارتكبها الاتحاد الروسي في سوريا
هناك جرائم مدنيين واطفال كلها موثقه في
هذه التقارير لكن هذه الدول تفلت من
الادراج داخل همم هذه القائمه واسرائيل
بسبب الحمايه الامريكيه
بتقديرك دبي ستستمر هذه المساله لانه واضح
انه اسرائيل لا تخفي وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه تقول بان اسرائيل تضغط
لعدم ادراج اسمك في هذه القائمه الولايات
المتحده الطريق لا تقول انا ضد ادراج اسم
اسرائيل تقول انا ضد اي تحديث لقائمه
العار يعني لا تمسه القائمه وبالتالي يصبح
الموضوع معوض تقريبا نفرض ان الرقم الذي
طرحته 740 طفل شهيد خلال عقد من الزمان
خلال عشر سنوات كان في دوله افريقيه او
احدى دول العالم الثالث من المؤكد ان اسم
هذه الدوله كان سيدرج في القائمه السوداء
من المؤكد لماذا لا يدرج اسم اسرائيل في
هذه القائمه بالرغم من هذا الرقم المجهول
المؤلم الخطير اولا لانها اسرائيل ثانيا
لانه فيه هناك حصانه امام المحاسبه امام
المجتمع الدولي
راس المحامين الذين يمنحون هذه الحصانه هي
الولايات المتحده اللي كمان هي همم ارتكبت
جرائم ولكن نحن نتحدثون عن اسرائيل
تعودت على عدم المحاسبه ولذلك هي لا تريد
لا زيارات لا تقارير وهي حساسه جدا لماذا
موضوع التقارير الامميه او التقارير
الدوليه وعلى فكره واجب علي ان اقول هي لا
تستهدف فقط همم اطفال فقط في الضفه
الغربيه او في غزه او فديه في مظاهرات
ايار همم ماضي شاب طالب محمد محاميد شهيد
فيهم الشرطي الذي اطلق عليه النار حتى
الان لم يعاقب همم لم يحاسب نعم فيهم
الفهم داخل خط الاخضر همم موسى حسوني
الشهيد في همم اللد مش طفل ولكن من قتله
ومعروفين بالاسم
احرار طلاقه بينما شباب من الداخل الذين
شاركوا في هذه الهدبه وادينو بالاخلال
بالنظام او تهم اخرى احكام قاسيه للغايه
بينما ما يوازي هذه المخالفات لدى
متظاهرين يهود التعامل هو بمعيار قانوني
مختلف ومزدوج اريد ان اعود لمقال جدع
شرت اليه انت قلت المجتمع الاسرائيلي
هو يقول تقريبا نفس المعنى هنا اقتبس لانه
المقال اولا هو عدد كثير من اسماء الاطفال
ومقاله كان بعنوان ماذا لو كانت جنازه كان
صبيا لو كانت صبيا ما احدا
هذه هي فقط لانها فتاه
فيقول همم هناك اقتباس يقول هذا المجتمع
المجتمع الاسرائيلي طبعا يغلق قلبه منذ
عشرات الاعوام ازاء الاف الضحايا الذين
يسقطون على يد الجيش الاسرائيلي من
الاولاد وشيوخ والنساء والصحفين اسرائيل
لا تريد ان تسمع ولا ان تعرف اسمه تريتش
الشخصيه المتطرفه المعروفه ليس هو المشكله
وايضا ليس بن كثير الارضيه التي مهدت
لقساوه القلب هذه جرى اعدادها منذ وقت
طويل قبل مجيئهما والان الكل يصرخ ماذا
سيجري يعني هنا نريد ان نتوقف هل هل قساوه
القلب هذه الان اصبحت هي النواه الصلبه
الاساسيه في المؤسسه الامنيه المصريه
القلب والبلاده والتعامل مع الاخر الذي
يخضع للاحتلال في هذه الحاله الفلسطيني
الذي يح- يخضع لاحتلال الاسرائيلي وكانه
لا شيء رقم هدف في اي دوله بالعالم يوجد
قبور للشهداء مع ارقامه
فقط في الحاله الفلسطينيه والاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
بين كبير رمز الفاشيه الاسرائيليه نعم هم
ظاهره خطيره ولكن في هذا العام
اللي الحكومه هي ما يسمى بحكومه التغيير
اللي فش فيها نتنياهو صحيح وهذا جيد ولكن
فيها وزراء اخرين وفيها يمين ويسار وعرب
عدد الشهداء الفلسطينيين الذين ارتقوا
برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هو اكثر من اي
عام منذ سته عشر عاما وانا كل هذا الكلام
للجنس قبل اسبوعين مباشره بدون اسم بدون
بنجبير مع حكومه التغيير المجتمع الدولي
يتعامل بكفازات ذهبيه مع هذه الحكومه
لانها تبتسم لانها تطلق تصريحات نوعا ما
برجماتيه وانتهازيه وبعض والمجتمع الدولي
يقبل ذلك اييه بعض العرب يقبلون ذلك
وتطلق النار بغزاره وكثافه وتقتل من
الفلسطينيين اكثر من اي فقره اخرى هذا يجب
ان يؤخذ بالنظر الاعتبار اليس هذا مدعاتا
لان يدخل في القائمه السوداء مثلا لان
يحاسبه الجمهور الاسرائيلي
ايه نعم اغلق قلبه قساوه وانا دائما اقول
هم لا يريدون احد ان يزعجهم في تل ابيب
وهم يحتسفوا يحتسوا قهوه الاسبريسو لا
يريد احد ان يقول لهم في شيء اسمه اراضي
محتله وابنائكم يطلقون النار او يدخلون
لمدرسه او يقتحمون مستشفى او يهني- يهينوا
مسن او طفل او امراه عندما تواجهم بذلك
يقول لك هذا مش ابننا او ان ينكر الحقيقه
او ان يبرر ذلك بان كل الفلسطينيين اما
ارهابيين او مشروع ارهاب
هل ده السلطه الفلسطينيه دكتور عمر عوض
الله هل لدى السلطه الفلسطينيه اي امل في
ان تدرج اسرائيل هذه المره في القائمه
السوداء
يعني كل العمل الدبلوماسي قائم على اولا
زعزعت هذه القلعه التي وضعتها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ما تسمى قلعه
الحصانه والافلات من العقاب لاسرائيل
زعزعتها وضرب اسسها ونرى بان هذه الاسس قد
بدات همم في في
الزعزعه بشكل او باخر من خلال ما نقوم به
بشكل دائم من حراقه قانوني وخاصه ان كان
مع ممثله الامين العام او مع الامين العام
نحو ادراج اسرائيل على قائمه العار
لمنتهي حقوق الاطفال في النزاعات المسلحه
ان كان من خلال المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
ان كان من خلال اي اليه متاحه للشعب
الفلسطيني من اجل مسائله اسرائيل
ومحاسبتها نحن لا نعتمد على الاحلام او
نعتمد على التوقعات نحن نعمل بشكل يومي
وحثيث من اجل ان الى هذه النتيجه باستخدام
كل ما هو متاح للفلسطيني من ادوات قانونيه
وسياسيه ودبلوماسيه بما فيها هذه الادوات
المتاحه التي تحدثت عنها من قواعد القانون
الدولي وغيرها من الادوات التي استحدثناها
بما فيها اا لجنه التحقيق المستمره في
جرائم اسرائيل
ان كانت على جانبي الخط الاخضر بما فيها
الذهاب الى محكمه العدل الدوليه كل هذا
سوف يزعزع هذه المنظومه الاستعماريه
الاسرائيليه ونظام الفصل العنصري لذلك نحن
متجهون نحو تسجيل اسرائيل على قائمه العار
وهذه الاولى المطالبات على همم جدول زياره
همم فرجينا قامه لكي يقوم الامين العام
بتسجيل اسرائيل على هذه القائمه في دوائر
الامم المتحده همم الدكتور عبد الحميد
صيام هل هناك ايه اشارات تفيد بان الامر
هذه المره قد يكون اكثر جديه ويقع ادراج
اسرائيل
لا اعتقد ذلك يعني بصراحه الامين العام
يعرف ان وضع اسم اسرائيل في القائمه
السوداء او قائمه العار له ثمن
ولو وضع وضع اسم اسرائيل من قبل في
التقارير السابقه تعرف هذا تقرير سنوي
يقدم في ايار مايو من كل عام وتقرير 2021
قدم ونشر وموجود
ولم تدرج اسرائيل رغم ال ال الانتهاكات
الكبرى التي ارتكبتها عام 2021 والتي
تحدثت عنها لو نشر اسمها لو وضعت في
القائمه لما انتخب الامين العام مره ثانيه
لانه يعرف ماذا جرى مع بطرس بطرس غالي
الامين العام الاسبق عندما تحدى الكيان
الصهيوني وذكر في تقرير حرفيا ان مذبحت
قانا كانت متعمده وبالتالي ذهبت اليه
وزيره الخارجيه اول برايت الى مكتبه وقالت
يجب ان ت- تحذف هذه الفقره ورفض ذلك قال
لا استطيع
وقالت له همم
كن على يقين بان هناك امينا عاما جديدا
سيكون هنا في الاول من يناير عام
1997 وهذا الذي حدث فانتخب كوفي عنان لذلك
هو يعرف حدوده ويعرف حدوده وهو همم سيضع
كل المعلومات التي تقدمها جامبا يعرضها
على الاطراف المعنيه يقدمون ملاحظاتهم
واذا كان فيه بعض الاخطاء احيانا يكون
هناك اخطاء او اسماء مكتوبه بالخطا او
اسماء
مدرجات وهمم حذفت فيما بعد لذلك عندما
يقدم تقرير في شكله النهائي الى مجلس
الامن والجمعيه العامه ومجلس حقوق الانسان
يكون قد وضع في صيغته النهائيه ولا يمكن
تغييره ويكون تم همم حذف من همم يعني تعرض
الامين العام للضغط بسببه يكون تم حذف هذا
الجهه او تلك ولكن اسمح لي دكتور صيام
عندما تقول واشنطن انها ترفض اي تحديث
لهذه القائمه همم اتركوها كما هي لا
تحدثوا شيئا لا تضيفوا اي اسم ولكن ماذا
لو الامر يستدعي اضافه
الصين روسيا ايران وتكون اسرائيل من ضمن
همم الاسماء هل هذا وارد في ال- في الفكر
همم
الامريكي في في هذه المساله تحديدا
يعني اضيفت اوكرانيا في التقرير الاخير
وهناك تفاصيل مهمه حول ما تعرض له الاطفال
في اوكرانيا ايه يعني الان سياتي التقرير
القادم لان تقارير انتهاك حقوق الاطفال
مستمر تصل الى الامم المتحده وبالتالي
سيتم همم تضمين اوكرانيا ايه في التقرير
القادم الذي سيغطي سنه 2022
وهذا تحديث للقائمه
نعم لا بد الا ان يكون هناك تحديث لابد
هناك مجموعات تختفي وهناك مجموعات تظهر
هناك مجموعه
ولكن عندما يتعلق الامر باسرائيل في
الولايات المتحده ستقف بالمرصاد لعدم
ادراجها ضمن القائمه هذا شيء مؤكد
الدكتور الطيبي في اسرائيل كانت اليسار
الاسرائيلي يلعب دورا الان تقريبا
يعني موجوده منظمات وغيرها يعني هذه ايضا
اختفى دورها في التاثير بالكامل
تقوم بدور مهم واود هنا ان اشيد بالدور
الجمعيات جمعيات المجتمع المدني والحقوق
الاسرائيليه اليسريه من جهه والفلسطينيه
الفلسطينيه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه من طرفي
الخط الاخضر لها دور هام في التوفيق
والمرافعه والتواصل مع المجتمع همم الدولي
اريد ان يشير الى نقطه ربما قد تحدث تغيير
انا لست على قدر كبير من الامل بذلك
الى حكومه اصبحت فيها الكاهنيه والفاشيه
خطا مش طيار مركزي التيار رسمي اعضاء
اعضاء زعران بالشوارع زي بين اصبحوا
سيصبحوا وزراء ولذلك عضو في كهان المنظمه
الارهابيه وهو منظمه امريكا اشارت اليها
واعترف فيها كم منظمه ارهابيه واسرائيل
كذلك
ربما من المجتمع الدولي عندما يرى حكومه
منه
الى اخره ان تكون هذه المهمه مهمه همم
انتقاد اسرائيل بديش اقول محاسبه لكي لا
ابالغ اسهل على المجتمع الدولي هل نحن
بهذا الاتجاه ربما على كل همم
لبيد وحكومه التغيير حذروا من ان صعود هذا
التيار الفاشي سيسهل مهمه انتقاد اسرائيل
ووضعها في الزاويه من قبل المجتمع الدولي
وربما الاداره الامريكيه وربما الجاليه
اليهوديه في امريكا تحديدا مش الجاليه
الرسميه الطلاب في الجامعات الامريكيه هم
اكثر نقدا لسياسات الاحتلال ربما مع هذا
التطور سيكون اسهل للمجتمع الدولي وللامم
المتحده ان ينتقدوا او ان يدخلوا همم هذا
الاسم
مقتل 740 اعتقد انه اسود مقتل 740 طفل
اعتقد انه عار والباقي على الامم المتحده
ولكن ليس فقط الامم المتحده الدبلوماسيه
فلسطينيه كما ك- قال الاخ عمر تنشط في ذلك
ولكن في هناك ضروره لرافعه عربيه قويه
بهذا الخصوص لان اطفال فلسطين هم ليسوا
ابناءنا فقط نريدهم ان يكونوا ابناء
الجميع همم دكتور هناك ايضا توجه داخل
اسرائيل
اشار اليه البعد بقلق بالقضيه ليست بن
كثير وليست مطريتش وليست نتنياهو هناك
توجه حتى
لتغيرات سياسيه ودستوريه عميقه بمعنى
تقريص حتى
المحكمه العليا صلاحيتها
لم يعد يعني هناك توجه انه لم يعد بامكانه
حتى ان تنقذ بعض قرارات الكنيسه يعني كيف
نفهم هذا السياق الجديد في اسرائيل
طلعت وما يسمى بالاصلاح ومش الاصلاح هو
تحديد وتبييض حريه المحكمه العليا نتنياه
كان معارضا لذلك هذه المحاوله جرت في
الماضي لماذا تغير موقفنا التنياهو فجاه
لانه في عليه ملف ومحكمه
نتنياهو يريد من وراء هذه التوليفه وهذه
الحكومه والاربعون وهذه التحركات وهذه
القوانين ان يصل الى وضع يستطيع ان يلغي
محكمته كما هي في اخر جمهوريه الموس
هل هو قادر على ذلك هذا ممكن يعني القوه
السياسيه
مع القانون الفرنسي او مع قانون فصل منصب
المستشاره القضائيه للحكومه يحولها مدعي
عام لحال ومستشاره قانونيه والمدعي العام
الجديد اذا تم تعيينه بعينوا بنيامين
نتنياهو من جماعته ويقول هذا الملف تشوبه
شوائب انا اقرر اغلاقه او اي طريقه اخرى
ولكن هذا ما يؤرق بنيامين نتنياهو حاليا
ملفه والملف الايراني ملف نتنياهو ملف
الايراني هذا ما يؤرك من يمين نتنياه
حاليا وهذا ممكن لانه اسرائيل ايضا كانت
تفتخر بان هي على الاقل في الداخل ومع
الاسرائيليين هي دوله قانون ومؤسسات
ولا شيء يعني فوق القانون على الاقل في
تعامل الاسرائيلي مع الاسرائيلي الان
وجونه وعلي نصف المجتمع الاسرائيلي كليب
جدا من هذه التطورات ولكن اريد ان اشير
الى بحث اجري قبل سنوات عديده في جامعه
حيفا لبروفيسورتنر ان هناك تمييز في
القضاء الاسرائيلي هذا القضاء اللي له
هاله امام مجتمع الدولي ما بين اليهود وما
بين العرب الاحكام الصادره بحق العربي في
الداخل هي اقصى بكثير من نفس الحالات ونفس
القضايا عندما يتم الحديث عن متهمين يهده
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور احمد الطيبي على
حضورك معنا في الاستديو شكرا ايضا لضيفينا
من رام الله الدكتور عمر عوض الله وضيفنا
من نيويورك الدكتور عبد الحميد صيام بهذا
مشاهدين الكرام نصل الى نهايه هذه الحلقه
مواعدنا يتجدد الخميس المقبل باذن الله
لبحثه سيناريوهات جديده سواء في قضايا
عربيه او دوليه دمتم في رعايه الله
[موسيقى]